all right thanks Alex for the
introduction and thanks for inviting me
you know that was great I don't need to
motivate anything so everybody's
motivated for thinking about robots and
autonomous systems that interact with
people so I'm dorsa I'm in computer
science and electrical engineering and
and my research is about algorithm
design for robots so I'm very interested
in designing algorithms for robots that
can actually interact people with people
and and are safe so when we think about
these autonomous systems so robots kind
of immediate like pictures that might
come to our mind are things like this so
we might have things like autonomous or
semi-autonomous driving or controlling
drones from the ground we might have
things like service robotics so like
doing tasks with robots in our homes
let's say or like robotic surgery and
and I know these systems are very
different from each other but one common
thing that they have like one thing that
they have in common with each other is
that they're all safety-critical and
they all need to interact with people so
each one of these systems is quite
challenging there's a lot of engineering
behind like getting these things working
but but the common aspect here is we
want to care about interaction and we
want to care about the safety of some of
these systems and when we think about
our robots today or autonomous systems
today they're not very safe or they're
not very interactive and and I have some
videos here that I was going to show so
so this is from the DARPA Robotics
Challenge in 2015 I'm sure a lot of you
guys have seen this any robot Isis that
gives a talk this is kind of their first
slide that look at all these robots that
is kind of the state of the other abadox
but they fail it's just who they do fail
but there are some success stories there
too and as I said there's a lot of
engineering there's a lot of hard work
that goes into like designing these
systems so yeah so this is like three
years ago and as you can see our best
robots today are not very good with
dealing like on certain situations or
dynamic situations and it's not just
robots it's autonomous systems in
general so here I have this video from
the Tesla autopilot crash where the
vehicle doesn't
detect a car on the side of the road and
there's this fatal crash and also when
it comes to interaction or not that
great especially if that interaction is
with people and this is one of my
favorite videos so in this case the
person has no idea what the quadrotor is
going to do next and then because of
that is really scared and he doesn't
know like how to interact with the
quadrotor and and if you're thinking
about designing algorithms for these
systems we should we should really think
about interaction and we should really
think about say safety and some of the
issues that goes on like when we are
thinking about design of algorithms for
robots so uh I say my research every
time I think about a robot or an
autonomous system there's usually a
human involved and there is an
interaction between them and their core
problems that I'm very interested in is
at the intersection of a bunch of
different field so I'm interested in
safe and interactive autonomy and that
requires a bunch of different fields
it's not like a single field that can
come and solve it so we are interested
in learning and control and optimization
because at the end of the day I want to
I want to control this system I want to
control my robot arm I want to control
my autonomous car and there's a lot of
learning and optimization going on there
which becomes very important I also want
to interact with people and there's this
emerging field and robotics called human
robot interaction and the idea is let's
think about how humans act around us and
how we can predict what humans are going
to do next and based on that plan better
so it's not as much about cognitive
science or getting into people's head
it's more about better design of like
mod algorithms for robots knowing and
predicting what people are going to do
next and the top area I've put there is
a serie called formal methods which is
an area in computer science it's
actually not taught in many schools so
when I go through like some schools like
they don't even know what it is but it's
basically this area which is about
proving guarantees and providing
correctness about systems so these
systems could be programs could be
circuits could also be controllers for
autonomous systems could be could be a
policy that's running on my robot so
what would be interesting is to look at
the intersection
of some of these fills where we can
bring in formal methods ideas and talk
about correctness of some of these
systems at the same time we can bring in
human robot interaction and think about
the interaction between humans and
robots and do algorithm design so that's
kind of the area I'm very interested in
today I'm mainly going to talk about
human robot interaction and how that
comes in I'm not talking about as much
about formal methods there are
implications of safety but I'm not
talking about that as much today all
right okay so I know I've motivated the
problem to be about any general human
robot system and and almost everything I
say today applies to any almost any
human robot system but I want to focus
on autonomous and semi autonomous
driving as the main subject of this this
talk and when we think about autonomous
or semi-autonomous driving maybe maybe
the first thing that would come to our
mind is Google's self-driving project so
that was one of the pioneer one of the
pioneers of thinking about autonomous or
semi-autonomous driving and then they
started with this notion of having semi
autonomous cars where the car was
driving autonomously on highways because
I was easier and whenever II was getting
off a highway it would basically
transition control back to the person
towing the person I'm getting off the
highway this is too difficult you got to
come and take over control and city
driving was human driven but all of a
sudden in May of 2014 Google decided to
completely change their plan and come up
with this new design which has this
fully autonomous vehicle and then go
with this fully autonomous vehicle and
eliminates the steering wheel and
braking pedal and it completely
eliminates the human driver so so they
decided to have this this new design of
fully autonomous cars and actually I
remember at the time I was at Berkeley
and Anthony lobanovsky was working on a
project came and gave a talk at Berkeley
and he actually mentioned one of the
reasons that they're going fully
autonomous is modeling humans seems very
difficult and this is a human inside of
the car so thinking about what the human
inside of the car is going to do next
can be very challenging and they decided
to just get rid of the humans have this
new design
but then if you look at like where
Google went immediately after that well
they have these monthly reports and in
only a span of a few months they had
eleven accidents in all of these
accidents the Google car was being
rear-ended so of course it wasn't
Google's problem it was it was the other
cars problem but what the question that
came to my mind at the time was well why
am I not being rendered 11 times instead
Oh a few months yes yeah and then yeah
so like I'm I save all maybe Google is
driving way more than me
Google is driving so much then actual
numbers is actually in the reports I
don't remember the actual number but of
course Google is going to drive more
than I drive but why am I not being
rarer than that many times and years of
driving like years of driving I don't
really I only had like one accident in
my driving experience of yours now and
if you think about it this is not a
problem and just Google this is a
problem with most car companies they're
trying to put these vehicles in a world
where humans don't behave by the book
like you might assume humans are going
to follow all the rules and drive like
at 15 miles per hour but humans are not
going to really do that because they
have their own kind of rules of playing
and playing when you're when they're on
roads so so we started looking at the
picture that kind of looked like this
this kind of motivated our pick our our
research so even if I eliminate the
driver inside of the car there are still
human driven cars around me there are
still pedestrians around me and I
actually need to think about the
interactions between between these other
agents it's no longer just cars so they
know they're they're driving be trust
now that was on yeah trucking is you
know a lot of people think trucking
would be the first thing that would be
automated because highway driving is
easier right so like if you can have
trucks automated on highways that can
solve a lot of problems but yeah so we
started thinking about this problem and
certain thing about autonomous cars and
if you think about autonomous cars well
autonomous car
today they try to optimize for reaching
for their destination so they try to go
towards their destination and at the
same time they try to avoid unsafe
regions of the road like the boundaries
of the road and if there happens to be
another vehicle on the road they usually
treat that vehicle as a moving obstacle
so basically try to do collision
avoidance with this moving obstacle but
if you think about it does this vehicle
it's not just the moving obstacle like
that happens to sit there right there's
a human inside it and the human has a
model of the world and also times for
reaching for his action so his goals so
think about it whether we want it or not
or whatever we plan for it or not the
actions of an autonomous car actually
effects the actions of other drivers and
and we actually need to take that into
account we need to think about these
effects and responses and and we do see
these type of behaviors in our everyday
lives for example if I want to change
lanes
I don't assume this car is a moving
obstacle what I do is I start nudging in
in front of the person and I expect the
other driver to slow down and respond to
my actions and then make room for me and
that's how I change lanes and and
unfortunately that's not currently how
autonomous car companies is it's
actually a video recent video of a more
car where the car is trying to change
lanes because it's an exit lane and it
starts signalling doing everything right
but it just can't do it because it
doesn't think about the actual
interaction that goes on between its
actions and yaller agents so it has to
actually exit come back around and do it
again so this is a problem right our
cars our autonomous cars today don't
really drive human-like the drivers
[Laughter]
there's rules how to get in and know how
to get in yeah it happened no no no
computer a regular drivers test driver
says would be interesting job yeah and
yeah no I could not be the goal leave to
me that sort of sounded off
but like then you have to kind of what
if you miss a goal so every time like
yeah you're right like like you have to
come up with the rulebook of like all
sorts of things to try I mean like you
would always like miss something so you
want to have something that is a little
bit more more like less handy Cody like
I would think would be awesome it like
I'm not suggesting we have that today it
would be awesome to have something like
that so it's sort of thinking about this
problem and and we thought about
modeling this interaction that goes on
between an autonomous car and a human
driven car as a dynamical system so what
I mean by that is I have direct control
over the actions of the autonomous car
so that's let me call that you are so
that's the steering angle and
acceleration for you for the autonomous
car and in some sense we have indirect
control over the actions of the human
driven car what's called at you H so
also that's the steering angle and
acceleration of the human German car and
when I say indirect control what I mean
by that is well if I take actions that
should affect the actions of the human
so in some sense I can indirectly make
humans do things and this is kind of
like an under actuated system if you
have taken a controls class and
electrical engineering you've probably
seen under actuated systems and this is
kind of like an under actuated system so
more specifically what we are doing here
is we're trying to find these actions
for the autonomous car that maximizes
some some objective some rewards
function and and that reward function is
a function of state and actions which is
usual but now I'm saying this reward
function should depend on the actions of
the human should actually affect humans
and the good question to ask is well
what does the human do I footing you a
chest are there as kind of these optimal
actions that the human is going to do
this model of the human and a good
question to ask is well how do I know
what UHS store is where does UHS star
comes from so the way we are modeling
the human in this work is is we are
assuming that our humans are
approximately optimizing their own
reward function let me call that our H
so they're kind of dismissed this is
like if you want to remember one math
from this stock this is kind of the math
that to remember this slide has a lot of
questions in it so the fur
question is go okay now that I put our H
here well how do I know what our H is
where does our H come from what does it
mean to have a reward function of the
human how do I come up with UHS star now
that I know it's our H like is it fair
to assume that humans are optimizing a
reward function what if they're not
optimizing that what if like we are near
access scenario and the human is not
really doing that so now that I have
that let's say I have the perfect
knowledge of predicting what humans are
doing even if I have that I'm putting
they're putting it up there how do I go
about solving that top optimization so
this is a nested optimization each one
of these rewards functions are non
convex nonlinear functions I need to
optimize in real time on the vehicle to
to go so so look even optimizing that
even if I know everything can be quite
challenging and then another question is
what should be the reward function of
the robot so what is our our look that's
a report design problem like what is a
good reward function to put under on the
autonomous car so I want to just briefly
talk about some of these questions I
want to first talk about the reward
function of the human unless there are
any questions on this other vehicles
that are kind of in our local vicinity
we do take into account their actions
into the formulation and now we assume
that we can affect them but most of our
work we just consider the closest
vehicle to me and think about the
effects and responses just between the
two cars we were doing some work now
that's thinking about it from the
transportation perspective of if I throw
in like a few autonomous cars how can
they help it something like traffic but
you're taking a very different view
there so like it's a very high higher
level Network level you I thought
control theory to me that's a final
problem
multi put multi output right you have to
say symmetry so humans on the other
computer but still so you can think of
this as a game theoretic gray bear you
don't have a symmetry like like you
actually have symmetric my actions can
affect you your actions can affect me
computationally you can't really solve
that in real-time
no these are nonlinear narcotic but
anyway but they're not like they're
going to fall into like local optima
anyways they're not going to like sorry
if you do just oh I talked to it yeah
learning does not solve that problem not
[Laughter]
okay so let me talk about the reverse
function of the human so what is that
like what are we actually doing in
figuring out whether of course function
is so the way we were approaching the
problem is running this algorithm called
imitation learning or specifically
universe reinforcement learning or
inverse optimal control same thing which
is this idea of let me collect
trajectories of how humans drive and
then from that learn a reward function
that if I optimize that I would get the
same trajectories so it's learning from
demonstrations
I collect demonstrations of how humans
like let's say pick up an object and
from a lot of these demonstrations maybe
I can figure out a reward function that
if I optimize I I can get the same sort
of behavior and the specific assumption
we are making here in this approach
which is called maximum entropy in
reinforcement learning is probability of
actions of humans is proportional to
exponential over rewards function so all
that means is if I have an action that I
think is better and it's going to take
me to a better state I'm going to wait
that action exponentially higher so
that's kind of the only assumption I'm
making on how humans are driving and you
also need to kind of like put a
structure around this reward function
the specific structure we are putting
here is assuming that it's a linear
combination of a set of hand-coded
features so these are things like
collision avoidance or staying within
your own lane or road or like this sort
of these are heading or your velocity or
these different type of features that
are representative here so the thing
that we want to learn at the end of the
day are the weights of the features
assuming that it's a linear combination
of these nonlinear features and and with
this approach I would have a model of
how normal human drivers are going to
drive so it have this reward function
that I can learn
offline from gathering trajectories of
how human stray and then I can put that
back in here
and I can go about solving this nested
optimization so we have to make a few
approximations here to make this
actually work in real time so I want to
go through some of these approximations
so the first approximation is well first
of all we don't have full knowledge of
the world so what we are going to do is
we are going to apply this approach
called model predictive control and then
the idea is I have a horizon and I'm
going to pick that horizon plan for that
horizon take a step and then refine and
the horizon I pick is based on how much
my sensor concerns or based on how much
computation power I have I might have
liked so much computation power to
actually optimize this in real time on
the vehicle and so this is a common
approach that that we do the second
assumption is going back to this this
game-playing thing that i was talking
about so so if you think about it the
actions of the robot affects the actions
of the human the actions of the human
affects the actions of robots robot
might know that and even like go further
in human might know that and then go
further in and you might have like
infinite regress already here like me
affecting you you affecting me and I'll
go forever but the way we are solving
this is actually as a stackelberg game
or as a leader follower game and the
idea is you are cutting the game at the
second time step I'm assuming my robot
is thinking it can affect the humans but
the humans are observing the optimal
actions of the robot and the reason that
this makes sense or works in this
setting is humans don't really play
chess when it comes to driving cars like
they're not thinking that many layers
down there's actually psychology studies
that talk about the fact that humans
only think two levels downwind or
driving like they're not thinking about
the effects of their actions so many
layers down when they're driving so so
in that sense this is this is sort of
okay and another reason that the this
assumption doesn't hurt us too much is
you're solving this in a model
predictive control fashion so your
repining at every time step so even if I
make an incorrect kind of decision even
if I don't like do the exactly right
the right thing to do here I can reap on
have come out of it in the next time
step and are finding horizon is like 0.1
seconds so you're planning for every
we're flying for every point five second
but the step is point one yeah any so
the MPC where a sensor is 0.5 but the
time step is point 1 yeah so so I plan
for the next point 5 seconds I take a
step next point one second I'm in new
place and I keep going how does that
interact with the human reaction time
yeah so they're studies looking at how
human so human reactions there are
studies that talk about human reaction
time and they can range from like two
seconds to like eight seconds right
depending on how much they're in control
or not and whatnot
so yeah so in this case this is the kind
of reaction time of the autonomous car
right so and then you're just observing
where the human is and you're not really
like putting in human reaction time in
this setup there's another work that I'm
not talking about it in this sock where
you're doing transition of control to
the human and there you're actually
thinking about human reaction time and
how much can I plan further and like
bringing in this idea of human reaction
time in the story but yeah human
reaction times are not that great
because those tend to just cross legs or
if you see in your an Anaheim by a
particular accent you see a car two
lanes over to the left you know it's
going to cut across you to get on the
ball that way yeah I'll come back to
that so I'll come accident or oh nice
lights and then I'll come back to your
question because like to slice from now
it's sort of answers the question but
doesn't completely let's come back to
that all right so I didn't and then
finally the final assumption we are
making here is
when you're modeling humans you're
modeling them as probabilistic agents
who are approximately optimizing this
reward function but when it comes to
planning which is when you're solving
this nested optimization you're actually
like assuming our humans are
deterministic and are deterministic
we're picking the maximum of the reward
function as opposed to approximately
optimizing it again the reason is timing
so the reason is I could technically say
the human is approximately optimizing
this and kind of add like add like a
noise factor into it but that can mess
up the timing of my optimization yeah
all right so so then when we try to
solve this problem the type of like as I
mentioned these are nonlinear non convex
functions so the best really that we can
do these days is to use gradient descent
type approaches so specifically we are
using quasi needs and techniques for
their fast convergence and even doing
that is not bad easy so if we're doing
something like gradient descent in this
set up I need to have a model of why I
need to have an expression representing
my reward function the thing I'm
optimizing reward function robot so I
already have that I also need to have an
expression for the gradient of the
reward function with respect to a
decision variable which is you are and
following chain rule I get that
expression and this particular
expression is actually not that easy to
find all its elements specifically this
term is the term that I can't just
immediately have the value for it which
is exactly how much the actions of the
robot is affecting the actions of the
human so this is that that gradient is
specifically specifying and Dada Dada
Dada amando value so what we were doing
in this case is a math trick really so
so what we are doing is we're using
implicit differentiation we are taking
to the reward function of the human
that's a function I can take its
derivative at the optimum which is UHS
start so I can take this gradient with
respect to you H at the optimum that
should be equal to zero that's only true
if my function is nice which is nice in
my case then I can take another gradient
of everything with respect to u R and
that's also equal to zero and pretty
much every term here can be computed
except
for this term so I can solve for that
term and that's exactly the missing term
that I had up there so I can basically
use this math trick of implicit
differentiation to extract out this
gradient put that back up there now I
have an expression for my gradient I
have an expression for my function I can
use my favorite quasi-newton method to
go about solving this so specifically we
are using this method called l-bfgs and
using tensorflow
to optimize things alright so let's look
at some of the implications of this so
imagine I have an autonomous car that's
the orange car I have a human driven car
that's a white car and let's say the
autonomous car wants to change lanes it
wants to go to the left lane so so
normally you would autonomous car is due
today is something like the very more
car so what they do is they look at the
velocity of the human driven car they
project that and they want to be safe so
they do something like this they slow
down and merge behind this vehicle so go
behind this vehicle what our car does
based on this nested optimization thing
that we are running it's actually
something different our car this nice
act a little bit more aggressively and
it cuts in front of but then that way
you never can change lanes like have you
driven on 101 on 101 if you want to
change lanes and if you don't cut in
front o people no one yes so I would say
this is more human like I agree that
this is not like this might be a little
bit more aggressive even right like
cutting in front of people doesn't seem
that safe if I want to have a telling us
cars that are super safe this is not a
very safe thing to do like doing that
but by doing that I'm actually like
violating not violating safety
conditions but putting myself at more
risk of colliding even but I'm actually
arguing that not doing that can also put
you at risk because because if you're
driving and waiting for every car to
pass like maybe the car behind you
doesn't realize that you're driving or
you're you're driving more mechanically
and then might actually hit you from
behind so so Anna
like I think human stripe like there's a
lot of times humans start like nudging
in and cutting in front of people and
making other people slow down by their
actions and this is if I have a model a
true model of the human so in this case
I can only do this if my model of the
human driven car is very good if I know
exactly this human driven car is going
to respond and slow down we also saw
some interesting other behaviors that
are definitely not human like so well we
saw was with running this algorithm we
had the scenario in the two cars arrive
at an intersection at the same time and
the autonomous card the orange car here
is rewarded for making the human go
first
so it really wants the white car to
cross first this is actually the heat
map of the reward function really wants
the human car to just pass worse so what
our car decided to do in this setting
was it was a little bit surprising
decided to back up this hard doing but
if you think about it by backing up the
car is making more room and making it
safer and more likely for the human car
to cross first and and I've never seen
any car autonomous or not autonomous
back up at intersections I computed that
but I've seen pedestrians there's a lot
of sensor Destin's back up told you that
you should cross first I'm not crossing
so it was kind of interesting to see
that the car just decided to use motion
to coordinate with the other driver
without like hand coding anything of oh
I'm at an intersection or not it's like
you just decided to use motion to better
like coordinate with this other agent
it's called signalling yeah yeah so we
don't have yeah so if we have if you
have an actual signal like you might
actually get signaling behavior but in
this case the only thing we have control
over is motion like that's the main
thing we have control over behind it
what would happen that always comes up
it's not going to echo it does have
collision avoidance it cares about
collision avoidance more than like doing
like this type of behavior so so there's
a balance between the different things
that it's optimizing collision avoidance
is definitely the first thing
two mice and the interesting thing is
this is something that we get in human
robot interaction - like if I have like
a robot interacting with me in a home
setting we are actually interested in
using motion to coordinate with people
better or use like legible motion that's
more like expressive for the human to do
things and it's kind of interesting to
get more expressive motion from cars in
this setup and they decided to
coordinate so of course none of this
makes sense unless it works with real
people so what we decided to do is we
decided to do a user study where we
brought in users to drive on a car
simulator with a steering wheel I'm
braking pedal so this was a very simple
simulator where you actually did some
studies later which fancier simulator
zouri would actually feel their forces
this is like very simple but what we saw
was for this scenario in a car decides
to backup the ideal human crosses first
so being on the other side of star means
crossing first and the purple shirt
actually corresponds to the ideal human
and by ideal human what I mean is this
is the learned model of my human this is
from inverse reinforcement learning this
is me simulating what the human would do
if the human were to follow this reward
function I've learned right so the
driving idea to Clara and I are all or
they're a user study both of them from
users and both of them were our grad
students our undergrads like running on
the simulator and what we saw is though
our users do something very similar to
the ideal human so the orange
directories corresponds to trajectories
of real users this is the average and
standard error of what the user soup and
they all cross first so they do
something similar to the ideal human and
they all cross first but if I'm not
planning with a human model if I'm doing
the usual thing of just planning for the
autonomous car without considering any
human models what my users decide to do
is something very different they do the
great trajectories and they all cross
second so the gap that we have here
between the orange and grey trajectory
is actually the gap that we can create
which is modeling humans and how they
would respond into our planning
algorithms which i think is kind of cool
all right so I think we kind of we all
agree to generate safe motion we need to
anticipate what this human driven car
might do next and and one way of
anticipating that is by modeling the
human as an agent who is approximately
optimizing maybe some reward function
that's one way of modeling the human but
then we kind of run into this video just
a little disturbing so this is a video
of a truck driver let me see if this
runs and then there is a vehicle on the
side of the road it's signaling it's
doing everything right for changing
lanes until like now and for some reason
this truck driver is not letting this
car in yeah so you might say maybe the
truck driver was sleep or very angry or
completely out of it I think you what
our driver was kind of aggressive to it
kept pushing if I was the other driver
at some point I would give up I would go
back to my lane me like this car is not
letting me in I'm done with this this is
not happening
so if you think about it well different
drivers have different driving styles
you might have aggressive drivers or
timid drivers or you might have
distracted or attentive drivers and and
when it comes to modeling humans we
can't just rely on a single driving
style where we assume everyone follows
the same reward function and and just we
can just go with that right we actually
need to differentiate between different
people's driving styles and different
ways that people respond to our actions
so we thought about modeling that into
our formulation and that was kind of
what we decided to do next so we took
our formulation and we just added a term
let's call that terms theta and theta
here just represents driving style and
what I can do is I can have a belief
over the driving style and I can update
that belief at every time step based on
the observations that I get so
observations would be how this car is
driving right next to me and
observations is probability of actions
of the human driven car given the state
and theta and I can just update my
belief of how the car drives so this
kind of works ok but there is a problem
with this
and the problem is we got to get lucky
to see any informative behaviors from
the white car here for example if I have
this turtle
it looks harmless and I might go my
whole life thinking that but it's holy
and you start poking the turned off that
you realize what sort of turtle you're
dealing with so currently you're kind of
stuck in the turtle situation you have
the white the the orange car it's kind
of observing the white car it doesn't
really know what the white car is going
to do next but it's just an impassive
estimation of the behavior of the white
car but if you think about it the
autonomous car is not just the passive
observer let's sits there right it's
also an actor it can take actions and we
have already seen like its actions can
actually influence other people right
you can cut in front of people and make
other people slow down for you so you
can actually make other people respond
so yeah the cars that I've been driven
by people can also be automated and can
have interactions with weight so if
every car was autonomous so my
coordinator yeah so if cars are
connected or liquid-like short yeah yeah
there is there's a big literature on
connected vehicles so connected so there
is a ton so there's a whole literature
on autonomous vehicle if there's a whole
digital and just connected vehicles I
know people definitely like thinking
about like maybe we should change the
infrastructure so cars can actually
communicate with each other that sounds
like a very reasonable thing to do so
there's a lot of research there in this
case no we haven't like looked at like
communication as much like explicit
communication as much but that quick
like solved many problems and if all
cars were autonomous and they could
communicate with each other like we
didn't need like traffic we wouldn't
need traffic lights like like everything
could just like go through and there is
actually research that tries to like
show that - for the other driver for the
other driver so if you could find out if
the guys once you see crashing cars per
head so you
cheating behind him the legal would
you're not supposed to do that according
to them so maybe what we are doing is so
let me go back to what you're actually
doing initiative and then doing
something so what we actually do is we
try to bring in these actions these urs
into our formulation and then what we
are optimizing for the reward function
of the robot is now a combination of
reaching the goal which is what it was
before this is what I was doing before
and another term that corresponds to
information gained so so this is a
difference between entropy over belief
of driving style of this guy and this
time step or says next time step how
much information can I get about this
driver so so while I'm doing this like
when I'm optimizing this reward function
my autonomous car is trying to reach at
school but at the same time it tries to
kind of gain information about is it
safe for me to cut in front of this
person or is it not so it tries to like
get as much information as possible and
and Landa here is the usual trade-off
that we would have between exploration
and exploitation not a robotics type
work so there is usually this problem
like how much they explore how much
should I exploit and you're using
standard techniques for setting lambda
okay so then my robot is going to
optimize an expectation over the reward
function because this is probabilistic
now and what we see is for changing ways
if I don't really know what type of
driver the white car is my algorithm the
thing it decides to output is it decides
to kind of nudge in like creeping a
little bit to see what happens
and if it decides the white car here is
a distracted human it goes back to its
Lane realizing this outer driver is not
going to I mean this is not going to be
a safe thing to do but if it realizes
that the white car in this case is
attentive it completes the marriage
because it knows that this vehicle is
actually going to slow down and make
room for it so it kind of updates that
reward function on they go online to do
a better behavior and safer behavior in
this setup by doing active information
yet
so again we decided to do user study so
in this case we had distracted drivers
distracted the driver drivers were
playing a game on a mobile phone they
were playing candy crush because I was
obsessed with candy crush time and and
what we saw was for an intersection
scenario this is a different
intersection scenario this is two cars
arrive at intersection but the orange
car wants to cross it doesn't
necessarily want the human the white car
to cross first but it doesn't know what
type of driver the white cars so if
you're doing passive estimation with
passive estimation the autonomous car
decides to just sit there just like does
nothing it sits and with passive
estimation it becomes really hard to
differentiate between distracted and
attentive humans they almost do the same
thing so these are like data from real
users again like I have the average and
standard error of different users that I
have in this case but if I'm doing
active information gathering my car
decides to nudge in creeping a little
bit and then we actually see the
behavior of the autonomous car here
decides to nudge in and if it decides
the person is attentive it keeps going
forward but if it decides to human is
distracted slows down and even goes back
at some point and when the robot does
this when the autonomous car does this
what we get is we actually get this type
of behavior and we can easily
differentiate between distracted and
attentive humans because they respond
very differently so the gap here is kind
of the gap that our algorithm allows us
to create because attentive drivers kind
of slow down and let you go first and
don't cross on the other hand like
distracted drivers don't see you and
they continue like going ok and we can
even have like a look at the belief of
driving style which was kind of the term
we were looking at so if in the case
that people are attentive belief of
attentiveness with active information
gathering goes higher but it's passive
estimation almost stays the same
throughout so it becomes really hard to
kind of figure out what people are doing
right so kind of just to summarize this
part of the talk really the key idea
here is that robots actions affect the
actions of other drivers or other humans
around them
and the thing we wanted to do was you
want to actually model those effects and
responses and even more than that
leverage those for better safety
efficiency coordination and even
estimation like as we see in the active
information gathering um so don't worry
the second part is not to lie but I was
wondering if I should skip parts of it
yeah so so that was kind of the big idea
that we had kind of been in this set up
and let me started thinking about the
human models a little bit more carefully
and thinking about well what is it about
the humans that we really care about
like looking at and and and yeah I'm
thinking about and yeah as you've seen
already well different people might have
different preferences about how any
given robot should act right and the
problem is getting demonstration so the
way we are doing this right now the way
that we modeled humans is by using
inverse optimal control or aniversary
unfortunate learning where we collect
trajectories of how humans do things
like we get demonstrations from humans
but getting demonstrations from humans
isn't always not that easy actually
demonstrating trajectories for robots
with more than a few degrees of freedom
can be quite challenging so there's
actually work trying to look at teaching
robots to do tasks and when you have a
robot with like seven degrees of freedom
it becomes really difficult to
demonstrate a good trajectory and even
tell operate that that robot to do a
task you know in a way that is perfect
so first off demonstrations can be
really challenging
so is that even a good way of thinking
about humans the second issue is there's
a study that looks at driving
demonstrations and what they throw is
they collect the driving demonstrations
and replayed the same demonstrations to
the same people and apparently people
don't really like how they drive
themselves it turns out they think their
driving is aggressive and they
prefer something that's a little bit
more conservative than their own driving
so then if that is true then driving
demonstrations are not even that
informative of of human's preferences of
how a car should drive so we started
kind of thinking about this other idea
that maybe instead of demonstrations we
can leverage comparisons as opposed to
demonstrations which can be very useful
observations of how a robot should act
and what I mean by that is what I can do
is I can have this this FET robot that's
going to do two different trajectories
and I can ask a user well which one do
you prefer you don't need to tell
operate this you don't need to like
actually get the robot do any of this
but which one do you prefer like what if
I if you were to compare this to which
one you prefer and if humans response
tells me in four it gives me information
if of if the human really wants the blue
Cup or the red Cup in this case in
driving we can do a similar thing we can
we can show two different trajectories
let's call those SCI asip and we would
ask him and so which one do you prefer
and in this case the humans response
gives us information about that reward
function I've been talking about so I
was trying to learn a reward function
representing what the humans are doing
and if the human tells me well I likes
ib oversee a that gives me information
about which rewards function is so that
gives the information of w dot v fib is
greater than W that's why a and W are
the weights the things we really want to
learn and fees are these features these
hand-coded features about each one of
these scenarios and they're evaluated at
scenario a or scenario B so let me just
move things around a little bit so the
question I'm really asking is let me
define this new fee and the question I'm
really asking every time from the human
is tell me if WI fee is positive or
negative like I'm just asking which
which side of like the hyperplane of W
dot fee I should be looking at so so
more specifically
so imagine WY is in a three-dimensional
space let's say that I only have three
ways so if that is the case well I can
actually assume that W is in a unit pole
because the sign of W is the only thing
we care about we don't actually care
about about the value of W the sign is
the only thing
trying to learn and we can sample from
this space and every time I ask if the
human in question that that that that
quarry or that question corresponds to a
hyperplane in this space so that's a
hyperplane of W dot V equal to zero and
the humans response gives me information
about which side is preferred so if the
human tells me W dash P is positive I
would take or negative I would take
either side of this hyperplane and then
row what I can do is I can rear a things
so I'm going to repay my samples and I'm
not completely removing the other side
because we're assuming humans are noisy
so they're not going to answer every
question accurately a hundred percent
right this is actually the noise model
we are using for the humans which is
using the Boltzmann distribution for how
humans act backed by some psychology
literature so so this is my first
question every time like this is my
first question the human tells me that
it's on this side of the hyperplane so
the second time that I'm coming up with
a question with a query it really
matters like what hyperplane that
corresponds to right I might pick a
question that corresponds to a
hyperplane that gives me the exact
information and quickly converges to the
thing I care about or I might ask
another question that doesn't give me
that information at all like it would be
a hyperplane that's not that informative
so we're kind of modeling this problem
as a volume removal problem like if
there's a volume here I'm trying to
remove as much volume as possible to
quickly converge to the particular W I
care about and and and do this in an
active manner with the minimal number of
queries I would need from the from the
human so the idea is when you are
thinking about generating these queries
is query Z to be generated actively we
should look at like the response of the
human from the previous time step and
use that response to actively generate
the next query and the big challenge
here is that when we are thinking about
these queries these questions that I'm
asking the human like this these queries
can lie in a very high dimensional space
I need to eat it's a continuous high
dimensional space and I need to think
about the initial position of all the
vehicles and the environment I need to
come up with the church
actors of all the other vehicles in the
world and I also need to come up with
two alternatives to informative
alternatives for for my own car and then
this can be quite challenging because
you're thinking about this continuous
high dimensional space and usually how
people approach this is they discretize
the world and they try to sample from
that discrete world but the way we're
doing this is instead of discretizing
the world we are directly synthesizing
these queries from the continuous space
so we are solving this as an
optimization problem as opposed to like
discretizing the world and sampling from
that so more specifically this is the
optimization so the problem we are
solving is we are trying to find a set
of queries those are fees that maximize
this minimum volume removed at every
time step so this is a volume inside of
that that Yunis ball that I was showing
you and then this term here is just
representing the minimum volume removed
using that specific update function that
we have up there subject to the fact
that these queries correspond to
reasonable trajectories that are
actually realistic and don't collide
with each other and are reasonable so so
this is kind of a problem that allows us
to create these queries and this is a
sub-module or optimization because our
objective is volume removed here and we
actually have methods that can do this
quite fast and minimize the number of
queries like required to learn a model
of the human so let's look at some of
the convergence results so what we saw
was our method converges much faster
than non active methods methods that
don't consider this previous response of
the human and in addition to that it
even converges faster that methods that
are active but discretize the world so
when we are continuously generating
these queries we can actually come very
much faster and what we saw was well we
actually ran this user study where we
asked users and ask for their
preferences in a driving scenario and
and what we saw was after like around 40
queries different users converge to very
similar and reasonable weights for each
one of these features so we have five
features for the driving case these are
the different features for the driving
case
this is the before figure of what the
weights are and as you can see the
weights are converging to very similar
results so each line corresponds to a
user
so all users kind of prefer a very
similar type of driving driving style
there are some differences between like
the purple one let's say purple ones for
collision avoidance so we kind of see
different convergences between these
different different users and in
addition to that well what we asked our
users was if they prefer this this
reward function that's learned as
opposed to other rewards function it's
like perturbations of the reward
function and it's small or large noise
and what we saw was the learned reward
function from preferences is actually
quite like afterwards people were very
happy with this particular learned
reward function and it kind of
represents what humans want in driving
all right questions so far so this is
kind of cool right this was the
formulation we're doing active learning
over humans preferences we were coming
up with a minimal number of queries to
quickly converge to humans preferences
and kind of our objective was I want to
do this fast I want to come up with the
minimal number of things I can do this
fast but problem with this optimization
is well synthesizing the queries
themselves is a little too slow so sure
I have like only 10 queries and with 10
questions I can figure out what humans
want but I ask my first question and an
irate like 20 minutes to come up with
the next question and I wait another
like 30 minutes to call over the third
question so synthesizing each one of
these queries can be really slow and and
the other problem is humans responses
come in sequentially so if you're doing
this active method you actually need to
wait for the net response of the human
to synthesize the next one so we have
kind of this sequential process and you
have to wait for too long to actually
get the answer for your for your
optimization so the idea that we had was
well maybe instead of synthesizing these
new new queries at every time step let's
just synthesize a batch of queries
let's just pick a good batch of queries
if I have that batch I can even paralyze
things if I want to learn the
preferences of a population I can
paralyze that and that that's probably
good enough
and that can make things much faster if
at every time step I'm computing a batch
so that changes the optimization to
something like this so every time I'm
running this optimization I'm optimizing
a batch of them so I'm optimizing B
number of queries at the same time and
and the big thing I want to I want to
make sure is is actually satisfied is I
want to make sure that the elements
inside of this patch are all so far from
each other there are also different in
our from each other so we run a few
heuristics honestly to make sure that
these elements in my batch are far
enough from each other and the problem
of coming up with a good batch is this
problem of maximizing the average
pairwise distance between the elements
inside of the batch so this is called a
maximum diversification problem it's
shown to be np-hard
so obviously we don't have like that
much of hope of finding the optimal
thing here but we use these set of
heuristics to just find the best match
possible so I don't want to go through
all these heuristics so the idea is can
be approximated and we are approximating
this with various heuristics so the
simplest thing is I'm gonna greedily
pick the best one at every time step and
pick the best elements here
but the problem ingredient is now like
if my batch size is 5 and I'm selecting
5 points from from here the pairwise
distance between them is still quite
small so so 1 & 2 are not that different
from each other so 1 & 2 are not giving
me that information how much information
so we've ran a few other heuristics I'm
not gonna go through all of them maybe I
just I'll just briefly talk about the
last one so this last method we are
using is called successive elimination
and the very successive elimination
works is we are gonna choose the closest
two pairs and then after that we are
going to remove the one with the lowest
entropy and we just keep repeating this
so I'm going to choose these two remove
the one with lowest entropy choose these
two remove the one with the lowest
entropy and I would keep doing that
until I'm left with the right amount of
samples that I need in this case it's 5
and these are kind of the five samples
that are far enough from each other and
are informative enough for my batch to
use every time I run the algorithm
all right so here are some some results
here so the green is going to be the
normal active learning method without
any batch like using any battery
obviously that's going to converge much
faster and everything else and this
successive elimination method also
converges fairly okay considering a kind
of a batch size here and obviously it's
going to be worse than the non batch and
fit but it performs relatively better
than some of these other heuristics we
also like looked at this for this
particular driving example so for the
driving example we kind of see the same
type of plot here for for convergence so
non batch converges fairly fast
successive elimination at some point
like reaches the batch method
the other interesting thing is the time
though so as you can see the time of the
non batch method is much much worse than
the successive elimination so timing
wise we would be doing a lot better when
we have like a good batch size and then
in addition to that like one question
might be well what is a good batch size
so so what would be a good size to pick
so here this plot is kind of showing
that so so we're looking at different
results of convergence for different
batch sizes and we have the timing of
each one of these batch sizes here so
the idea would be if you have like
limited time then you can pick your
specific time and that gives you a batch
size and you kind of see the convergence
results there
we don't have theoretical results
connecting these two here so this is all
done like experimentally here okay all
right so I'm gonna just quickly show
this for two example so this is for the
driving case so with no prior preference
no idea what I'm doing so I'm doing
crazy things and then after 30 queries
our car is learning heading preferences
so it learns like what sort of heading
it should keep and then after 70 queries
it finally learns to keep heading and a
new collision avoidance and and finally
just learns humans preferences so this
is learning humans preferences without
any driving data it's just from like 70
comparisons between between generated
trajectories using the batch active
learning method we've also like ran this
for a bunch of different experiments I'm
not showing all of them the only thing I
have here
is the tosser example so this is a
modular example where we have an agent
that is tossing a ball inside either one
of these baskets the green basket is
preferred so at the beginning it doesn't
know what the preferences is and over
time it kind of learns how to throw a
ball and how to throw it in a basket
it's kind of cool because it's just like
on its own from comparisons it's
learning throwing and learning how to
throw it in a basket so like it's a lot
of things to learn basically all right
okay so just to summarize kind of this
part of the talk well the idea here was
demonstrations getting demonstrations as
difficult demonstrations can be noisy
can not be really what we were looking
for so maybe we should be looking for
something else like comparisons pairwise
comparisons and try to use pairwise
comparisons to learn humans preferences
and specifically we looked at this this
active method where we actively
synthesize new queries to quickly
converge to the true human reward
function and minimize the number of
queries required to learn humans
preferences and then after that we
realized well each one of the queries
take a lot of time to be generated so
instead can we use a batch method and by
using a batch method will we reduce the
query generation time and in addition to
that we can even paralyze things because
if I want to learn the human preferences
of population I can just run run them at
the same time and I don't need to wait
like sequential you wait for the for the
responses to write okay so some of the
directions is we were thinking about
going from here like about this project
is if you think about it I've been
looking at the single reward function
that's a linear combination of a set of
features right and that reward function
alone might not be very representative
of what humans are doing so we are
trying to look at more interesting
models of humans like mixture models and
trying to learn humans preferences when
we have these more complicated models of
humans and there are some interesting
theoretical questions there because her
voice comparisons are actually not
enough for us to just learn like these
mixture models if I have a mixture of
gaussians
say representing what my humans do which
is a good model of humans because maybe
humans in Boston Drive very differently
from humans in power otters so so then
you you actually might have a mixture
model so if you have that type of type
of model pairwise comparisons are just
not enough we actually need to like go
to a higher level and ask for a full
ranking and all trajectories to try to
learn this so those are some of the
theoretical directions we were looking
at you're also thinking about combining
comparisons and demonstrations and then
kind of get the good side of the both
worlds to to quickly learn better models
of humans I don't know what I have after
this oh so I was just gonna wrap up so
this is kind of the beginning picture
that I had oh these are some of the
things we were doing in my lab today so
we are interested in human robot
interaction and collaboration
so in general we are very interested in
collaboration shared control trying to
predict humans intent from also just
visual data you're looking at learning
tell operation math so how can I like to
operate a robot with high degrees of
freedom to do tasks you're interested in
social navigation so if I have a robot
that navigates in crowds of people what
sort of actions should it take how
should it interact with people and also
you're doing some work around safety
where we are thinking about safe
learning so if I'm actively gathering
information if I'm exploring can I do
that in a manner that's that's
considered safe like how would I how
would I do safe exploration about the
environment or the state of the other
agents so these are some of the
directions that you're currently looking
at in my lab there are some other
assertions that or entry I don't want to
go through your slides
sure Oh slicer real quick
another another problem that we might
have is if you remember my nested
optimization this was kind of the
optimization I had there right I was
assuming that my humans are optimizing
this our age this reward function and
this is assuming humans or optimizers of
a rational rewards function and if you
think about humans tend to be not very
rational or optimizers and it's also
hello today so that's Y all of the care
that's true
actually what we are looking at right
now so we aren't interested in thinking
about how human stripe and it comes to
near access and is not this scenario but
your accident scenarios and there's a
lot of interesting work from behavioral
economics that thinks about similar type
of problems like sadya of prospect
theory which is thinking about how
humans behave when it comes to high gain
and high loss situations and they might
not be optimizing a particular reward
function and kind of some of these ideas
is the fact that humans are not
irrational but they're bounded rational
so they have bounded resources maybe
they have about a time about it memory
quickly like this site and it's
challenging scenarios and the idea is
can be used some of these some of these
knowledge that exists in behavioral
economics to model humans and in
scenarios that are challenging or in
your accident setting
yeah maybe let me just talk about this
real quick to so um so that's all good
typing model humans maybe I have models
of my human driven cars and at the end
of the day I need to plan for my
autonomous car I need to figure out what
the autonomous car should do and
sometimes when i model humans like this
two safest strategy for the autonomous
car just doesn't exist like if I want to
be safe and if I want to like assume my
humans falling to some some space then
then sometimes I just cannot find like
my controller will come out in feasible
or unrealizable and you would say well
that just doesn't exist the thing you're
looking for is not going to be safe and
then this is not a crazy idea even
Google that's trying to go for your
tournaments they have around 300 this
engagement in this engagements and 400k
miles of driving so that's about oneness
engagement per month for a typical
driver this engagement means that the
car doesn't know what it's doing is
transferring control to the human or the
human feels unsafe so the human is going
to take take over control so if you
won't have that many dis engagements we
need to have better ways of like
handling these challenging scenarios and
and one way is this idea of transfer of
control but I know if people have mixed
feelings about transfer of control to
the human especially like considering
humans reaction time if it is eight
seconds lots of things can happen in
eight say
but we should have better ways of
thinking about this challenging risky
scenarios maybe like have a supervisor
that takes over control and and I'm sure
that's something that Google is thinking
about these days too but in general like
we are interested in being able to
diagnose and repair and understand what
what caused the failure and then again
this is not just about cars it's about
human robot interaction - if a robot
fails at doing a task it shouldn't just
come out and say well sorry that didn't
happen I failed it should just come out
with some reasoning of why it felt like
what felt like what was it that you
weren't able to do and have this kind of
iterative process between the human and
robot to just do tasks better and and
finally kind of another direction that
I'm very excited about these days is
taking this whole idea of human robot
interaction in autonomous driving to a
higher level when we are thinking about
networks of vehicles and we have
multiple autonomous cars and multiple
human driven cars and thinking about how
interactions between autonomous and
human driven cars can affect kind of
social objectives like like traffic or
yeah so for example if I have a set of
trucks that can platoon and get behind
each other maybe that can actually help
with the traffic that you would see on
the roads and how can we like do that in
a in an efficient manner all right
that's all this is a lab I can take any
questions
[Applause]
so generally it seems that creating
cases is really important with these
mathematical models so you know like how
is the human driver going around where
the environmental conditions so how many
of these cases are inherently built in
models versus the model was creating new
categories better than anything yeah and
it's so that's kind of like test case
generation right like if I want to make
sure that my models of the car driving
is going to work out well I need to
generate new test cases so another
project you're looking at right now it's
actually automatic test case generation
like how can we automatically generate
new interesting test cases the type of
approaches we were thinking or similar
to the active learning type of
approaches I was talking about so there
we were actively generating scenarios to
figure out model of human now we want to
actively generate new scenarios and
informative scenarios that can tell us
something about like driving of the
autonomous vehicle so that works very
well if everything falls into the model
that I have in my simulator the other
problem is most of unsafe settings could
happen because it's not even in the
simulator so it's not it's like unknown
unknown I didn't know that that I should
model that in my simulator and those are
harder to catch it yeah how much data do
you have access to of actual driving
scenarios and can you use that to make
okay we appear to have but a big batch
of Boston drivers or New York drivers
versus simpler more civilized California
[Laughter]
we're talking about here we collect our
data on a simulator so we have the
simple simulator where we can do fancier
controlling and then we have this force
fact a force feedback simulator where we
actually fill the forces and it's like a
little bit more realistic and here at
Stanford you have the cars centers a
Center for Automotive Research so
they're they basically have like a Honda
sitting in a room kind of like this
and there was like a screen around you
and you can basically sit in the Honda
and drive and that's kind of where we
look at collecting data we had some data
from car companies too but most of it
was just like 101 driving data and yeah
so the how much matter is if it is all
like 101 driving it it kind of like all
looks the same so so the informativeness
of the data or kind of like diversity of
the data is the main thing that would be
interesting for us to look at yeah I
haven't seen much public data on like
Boston driving or like knowledge of
driving yeah every company for example
is collecting just their own camera
observe a lot about how people actually
respond to experiments yes so there is
some data sets of like just cameras so
there's this ng same data set which is a
public data set that's online that is
just a camera looking at a highway and
looks at like basically cars arriving so
depends so for the traffic work for
you're looking at like traffic data like
that high-level data of just cars like
passing by it's probably good enough for
like Nora level I won't actually control
this vehicle I want to know the location
of my car I kind of haven't want to have
a good sensing over the other drivers
are so so for that it's harder to find
like this proximity they're doing the
experiments you want to do yes super
example yeah you're saying I could put
like a sensor on my own car and then
drive around and get some data
essentially sensor every car on the road
because they're all doing experiments on
each other hmm
yeah but like we don't have sensors on
all the cars and you don't have to its
optics what I said i watch a car and I
noticed it doing goofy stuff
uh-huh people drive that way yes yeah so
so it's a combination of like that ng
smell you're like I'll have images of
cars driving versus like some of these
works like you could technically work
from images if
like try to what we're looking at is
follow them for a while to notice
because each car is going to be a
different behavioral function and then
there's how they respond to each other
and some people interact badly with each
other and some people don't
yeah so we could generate a bunch of
different models yeah and that's
actually very interesting because like
when I think about this the interaction
work I talked about you might say like
I'm going to slow down here because I
just saw that car like taking over that
other car so you look at the interaction
of other cars with each other and that
affects your actions too which is not
something we have model we haven't
modeled that here but that totally
affects your actions too and that's kind
of another layer of thinking about it it
certainly gives you a bottle of both
cars the second it puzzles me how you
can get rich information about what the
other driver is doing with the planning
horizon less than the human reaction
time so um the model of the human yeah
so the axial information so because for
the first book you're not doing active
information gathering right if you're
not doing active information gathering
the model of the human is learned
offline so I'm not like you know you
know like not you're not trying to
update it in an online fashion in the
first work right so I'm just looking at
how humans drive are fine then in an
online fashion I just see what their
stake is and I just evaluate my function
of my reward function in that state so I
don't need to like observe a history of
the human or like 0.5 seconds of human
driving to update that because I already
have a model of how normal drivers drive
for the other kind of active
information-gathering type of work
you're doing the nudging in type action
so so with that you cannot kind of
observe what people are doing and have
this belief kind of going over time it's
not just so the belief is going to be a
longer-term thing it's not just for the
planning horizon so my belief of the
driving self the person if it is 50/50
aggressive not aggressive is I'm going
to keep that belief until I see that
like like for the whole period of time
that I see that car that question
oh it seems like that seven or eight
second human reaction time is from
reading a book in a it's fully
autonomous car to getting the full
situation of the two second is actually
reacting some easy actually thing is
quite large I think it's the wrong like
I think it's quite I don't remember the
like literature like that there's a
study in Germany that looks at kind of
like all versions of it but I don't
remember the exact number but I remember
it was high you have a one-foot ruler
and you have somebody let it slip from
their fingers and with you only to the
other end most people can catch it
before it goes through and that's a
quarter-second yeah what we're driving
like specifically for driving right I'm
I'm very sure that it's like longer or
very long ger than the planning horizon
that even a time like no multi miss Mars
use like not even like model on humans
like usually the Thomas cars use a point
two second like we're buying so it's
definitely like longer than that yeah I
mean the state of the amygdala is gonna
affect which mode the humanism yeah so I
don't know tell us like the exact
details of it but from like what we see
like they have started thinking about
like different models and kind of taking
that into account as opposed to
previously like I remember like I don't
know two years ago like even when you
talk to car companies so they they would
model humans is they would model them as
agents who are just going constant
velocity so if they're going 60 miles
per hour they're just going to keep
going 60 miles per hour it's not that
bad honestly because if you're doing MPC
like even if you assume this person is
going 60 miles per hour
Oh next second like it's not hurting you
too much it just makes you to take like
more conservative actions because you
think that person is not going to be
ever affected actually you know going
too fast and then you're getting close
so hard you get this big you know sound
and you kind of like makes you a lot of
companies are heading to now like trying
to drive the human can get to operate
the human yeah yeah so now goes the
shares control so they're like different
ways don't like they make sure it comes
into human robot interaction to me so
that's it yes thank you
Terry today operates UAVs with more
people environment that you're running
the software compiler and you know just
all of that crap has to work nice to
work yes yes I realize here I'm assuming
everything if they don't work the
meatiness we can just make algorithms a
little bit more conservative so if I can
model that that well with some
uncertainty the system is going to fail
maybe I shouldn't trust my actions as
much so so you can kind of just
propagate that uncertainty back into
planning and make your actions a little
bit more conservative so if I think my
model of the human is not exactly right
or if I think I can't sense the human
like exactly right with this probability
I'm not going to cut in front of the
person I'm going to like slow down
you